Are you worried about low rice yields?
Let's fix that with top transplanting
tips. Rice is a staple crop and
transplanting it right can make all the
difference. Here's what you need to
know. First, timing is crucial.
Transplant your seedlings 25 35 days
after sewing for the best results. Next,
prepping your patty field. Level it well
and add organic manure to enrich the
soil. When it's transplant time, you
have two options, manual or machine
transplanting. For manual space,
seedlings 20x 20 cm apart. For machine,
follow the manufacturer's guidelines.
Post transplant care, keep your field
flooded for the first 7 10 days to help
seedlings establish. Also, watch out for
pests and weeds. Address them promptly.
Proper transplanting leads to stronger
plants and better yields. Follow these
tips and watch your rice fields thrive.
If you found this guide helpful, like
and share it with fellow farmers. Happy
transplanting. Hash rice transplanting.
# farming tips hash sustainable
agriculture